on est tombé sur sur des cédants qu'avec
la volonté de remettre la ferme et on a
eu toutes les clés pour le faire dans
des meilleures conditions possibles et
du coup aujourd'hui on a pu s'installer
en couple sur cette ferme qui nous fait
vivre et les qui nous fait vivre
oui parce qu'on est passionné par ces
matières pourquoi est ce que votre
épouse est venu vous rejoindre sur
l'exploitation au mois de janvier cette
année
eh ben c'est essentiellement pour la
qualité de vie voire profiter de nos
trois enfants me voir grandir et puis
aussi pour montrer un peu aussi à
l'extérieur au monde extérieur que c'est
possible de vivre à deux sur une ferme
c'est sûr qu'en couple c'est plus facile
qu'avec deux tiers être associés mais
c'est quand même une belle qualité de
vie est aussi une reconnaissance mais de
ceux de ce travail qu'on fait on
agriculture bio et qui nous permet de
par sa plus value de de faire vivre un
foyer sur une petite ferme
on est bien d'accord vous êtes à deux
sur cette exploitation parce que
actuellement le lait à comté bio est
très bien payé aux paysans
oui très bien pays je sais pas si on
peut dire que c'est très bien payés
c'est bien payé
c'est un travail qui est valorisé c'est
une reconnaissance parce qu'on a quand
même des intrants qui nous coûtent plus
cher les intrants c'est les intrants
balala céréales en particulier chez nous
qui est plus du double du prix d'une
céréales conventionnelles et aussi un
effort de tous les jours de se passer de
maximum d'antibiotiques de l'engrais
chimique
et aussi de glyphosate y en a pas depuis
le depuis plus de 10 ans sur cette
exploitation il n'y a pas eu de
l'engrais chimique de glyphosate de tous
ces produits qui nous sont interdits en
agriculture bio donc c'est une c'est une
vraie valorisation de notre de notre
travail de tous les jours je suis
toujours un peu frustré de dire que
c'est bien payé je pense que c'est enfin
que c'est très bien payés c'est bien
payé s'est correctement pays mais parce
que le lait à comté bio n'a jamais
atteint ce niveau de rémunération
voilà c'est aussi parce que peut-être
que le consommateur commença à vouloir
mettre le prix dans un produit qui sait
au sein de qualité et c'est aussi pour
le consommateur une façon de s'exprimer
de sa volonté d'avoir un produit bio
dans son assiette
vous avez désormais des origines
lointaines agricole c'était vos grands
parents qui étaient paysans
qu'est-ce qui a fait que vous êtes
décidés pour devenir agriculteur cet
attrait pour les vaches il a toujours
été en moi ce qui m'a décidé
c'est surtout l'accessibilité qu'on a eu
pour ce métier c'est un cédant qui nous
a qui nous a ouvert sa porte avec un
prix de reprise qui étaient raisonnables
qui nous a permis de nous installer sur
cette ferme d'en vivre
et aussi de pouvoir faire nos choix et
aujourd'hui c'est ça qui nous qui nous a
permis d'être paysan est d'être d'être
bien installés confortablement et son
souci économique avec une viabilité une
vie une vivabilité vraiment accompli
alors michel votre ces dandys qui
l'aurait pas forcément pu travailler
avec vous vous dit la même chose
oui mais ça c'est sûr je pense conflit
de générations oblige et puis aussi
parce que je pense qu'on arrive on a 30
ans sur une exploitation on a envie
d'être chez soi
je pense plus que quand on arrive trop
jeunes sur une sur une ferme donc c'est
important pour moi
de d'avoir affaire à moi c'était aussi
une accord de départ de se dire que
quand je serai paysan ici je serai tout
seul chacun se fait chez soi et aussi
parce que j'avais là j'avais charge
d'âmes comme on dit j'ai mes enfants et
ma femme ou à la maison à côté et du
coup c'était le moment pour moi
d'assumer cette rôle de père de famille
est donc le ben voilà c'est pour ça que
on n'a pas cherché forcément à
travailler beaucoup ensemble et je pense
que ça aurait été oui difficile une
ferme bio c'est ce que vous recherchez
est ce que ça a été difficile de trouver
alors à la base non je cherchais pas
forcément une ferme bio je cherche à une
ferme qu'ils puissent axée sur le
pâturage où les vaches à l accès aux
pâturages toute la saison et du coup
cette ferme était en bio
c'était la cerise sur le gâteau enfin
surtout que surtout que les viabilité
économique a été prouvé depuis le départ
du coup c'est très rassurant pour nous
de savoir que qu'on s'installe sur une
exploitation qui qui tourne bien donc le
bio était pas une idée départ mais
j'apprends à vivre avec on va dire enfin
la travailler en bio et c'est tellement
valorisant pour la personne que
aujourd'hui on ne se penserait pas
paysan autrement quand bien même pour
vous ce n'était pas une idéologie de
départ non c'était pas une idéologie de
déport car c'était réalité convaincu
femme vous êtes converti quoi oui on
s'est converti plus qu'on a converti la
ferme car elles étaient de janvier
on s'est plutôt convertino c'était
c'était pour nous un mode de production
un peu inconnu mais en ayant remplacé
dans mon métier précédent des paysans
bio je voyais aussi que c'était c'était
faisable et s est aussi dans l'air du
temps de se dire qu'on va faire
attention à l'environnement qu'on va
faire attention au bien-être animal
qu'on va faire attention à ce qu'on
propose comme produit au consommateur
donc tout naturellement c'est
c'est venu à nous comme on est venu à la
bio dernière question michel dit que si
le scénario de il devait leur écrire il
changerait rien vous diriez la même
chose oui je pense oui
d'ailleurs je pense que le scénario
n'était pas écrit c'était juste
c'était comme ça c'est je pense que
voilà la vie nous offre des choses des
fois qu'ils sont qui sont au-delà de ce
qu'on peut écrire ou prix war c'est
cette je pense il ya une étoile qui
veille sur nous comme comme quand on
trouve son amour comme quand on a ces
prémisses enfance et c'est comme ça
c'est la vie est ainsi je pense c'est un
coup de foudre en fait ça s'est confirmé
très vite et ça se passe que quoi parce
que c'est trop bien vous l'imaginez pas
aussi bien que ça mais parce que c'est
une belle histoire
c'est une belle histoire et j'espère que
beaucoup beaucoup comme nous vivrons ce
cette concrétisation d'un rêve voilà
d'être paysan